da-da-da-da-da or sure to filter doctor
woman and that was in guys talk to
children or tsukimiya was out gallons of
water blowing she doing she's join the
team he she doing
chia-chia
sobbing Papa Mia Google idea Ysidro en
todo Nevada don't register you kiddo
vatos reason todo bien Serafina whoa
pour into a CD a reversal single
crystalline T Archaea Eva's da da da
where ddoddo ah yah wah conversation I
don't even go party hi da da da da una
run errands ladies to join us ways of
shortages sure
wasanta which are we are drawn to the
general officer evil cut or swallow
become confident agenda
yay black burger inside where which are
from the yeah - ah - ah - goa gajah mada
for me da Wanga schwa coyote coat indeed
Oh Cindy for Mia yay
todo para la salida de muchacho and bad
where Toledo pooja we tanto tanto la la
violence hakuzo-su no that was a sight
of the Egyptians for ending a shortage
her quicker on the yeah
without you I'm through the fish are
there are other solace in here now I
wasn't indeed Allah Tata
ever